"Золотий" паспорт. "Золота віза".
Звучить красиво, проте у майбутньому їхній блиск потьмяніє -
принаймні в країнах Євросоюзу.
Продаж громадянства ЄС відстежує, зокрема британська Guardian,
за даними якої паспорт Кіпру, скажімо, мають Ігор Коломойський,
Геннадій Боголюбов, Костянтин Григоришин, Олег Дерипаска
та принаймні ще десятки українців та росіян.
Торгівля громадянством - прибутковий бізнес,
це дозволяє, за даними МВФ, кожна четверта країна світу.
В Євросоюзі таких держав три:
Мальта, Кіпр та Болгарія.
Необхідні інвестиції: від двохсот тисяч до двох з половиною мільйонів євро.
Для набуття громадянства не потрібно
ані жодних тестів, ані проживання у країні.
Проте ще 20 країн ЄС пропонують так звані "золоті візи" -
дозволи на постійне проживання -
в обмін на фінансові вливання:
від Естонії та Польщі до Великобританії, Франції та Люксембургу.
Міжнародні організації Transparency International і Global Witness підрахували:
за останні десять років в Євросоюзі продали
майже 100 тисяч "золотих віз" і 6 тисяч паспортів.
Що принесло загалом 25 мільярдів євро.
Брюссель нині оприлюднив аналіз програм "золотих віз" в ЄС.
Виявилось, країни-члени часто не перевіряють ані самих заявників,
ані походження капіталів:
байдуже, чи перебувають кандидати під європейськими санкціями,
або вдома проти них порушили справи щодо корупції,
відмивання грошей чи ухиляння від сплати податків.
Завдяки чинній системі заїхати в Європу
можуть не лише корупціонери та можновладці з авторитарних держав,
але й організатори злочинних груп.
Які зазвичай обирають ті країни ЄС,
що не мають угоди про екстрадицію з батьківщиною так званого "інвестора".
Крім того, держави самостійно ухвалюють рішення щодо "золотих віз"
і не консультуються з рештою членів ЄС.
Досі немає і спільної бази даних відхилених заявок.
Натомість користь від інвестицій громадян третіх країн -
не така вже й велика.
Найчастіше вони інвестують у будинки та квартири,
а не в промисловість, робочих місць не створюють,
платять мінімальні податки.
А якщо врахувати права та можливості,
які пожиттєво надає європейський паспорт - стає зрозуміло,
що непокоїть Брюссель. Наприклад, громадянин Мальти
може не лише вільно пересуватися теренами Євросоюзу
і працювати у будь-якій його країні,
а й має право на безвізовий в'їзд туристом до США.
З другої половини 2018-го
Євросоюз почав активнішу боротьбу з відмиванням коштів.
Протягом року усі країни спільноти провинні адаптувати
нові значно суворіші правила контролю
над переміщенням капіталів та джерелами їх походження.
І вже з січня 2020-го
вони стануть обов’язковими для всіх банків ЄС.
Це неминуче потягне і масштабну реформу програми
залучення іноземних інвесторів -
ера "золотих віз" та паспортів відходить в минуле.